age so as they do that good afternoon my
name is Ana Stefan and I'm with the Scot
Institute for energy innovation we're
going to move right into our next panel
we have two panels before our next break
and this panel is on the insights and
innovations in natural gas and
traditional fuels so our moderator for
this session I'm very honored to
introduce
so dr. Jared L Cohen is the president
emeritus and university professor of
civil and environmental engineering and
engineering and public policy and he's
the Wilton a Scott Institute for energy
innovation director emeritus at Carnegie
Mellon University dr. Cohen will be the
moderator of this panel and he served as
Carnegie Mellon's eighth president from
1997 to 2013 during that time the
university made progress on many fronts
including teaching and research
international activities diversity and
economic development in southwest
Pennsylvania dr. Cohen is the former
director of CMU's Wilton East Scott
Institute for energy innovation morgan
o'brien also joins us he's closest to me
here he's the president and chief
executive officer of people's natural
gas company LLC he is in this capacity
he's responsible for the company's
strategic operational and financial
performance under his leadership
people's mission is to make the lives of
all of its customers better Pat Getty
has been the president of the Claud
Worthington Benedum foundation since
1999 in addition to his vision shared
board position he's a member of the
governing board of imagine West Virginia
vision shared independent Policy
Institute he also serves on the policy
committee of the southwestern
Pennsylvania Commission and is a fellow
of the University of Pittsburgh
Institute of Politics michaelm are
joined us from shell Pennsylvania
chemicals where he is the business
innovation lead he's been both a senior
communications leader in both of the
private and public sector for more than
two decades in 2012 Marr joined shell
and has since worked in different roles
covering shells u.s. chemical assets and
shells petrochemical project in Beaver
County Pennsylvania
Stacey Olsen in the center is the
president of Chevron Appalachia LLC a
position she assumed in June of 2016
she's responsible for developing leading
Chevron for leading Chevron's business
unit
that develops natural gas from shale in
Pennsylvania Ohio and West Virginia
Colson also is a board member of both
the Center for Responsible shale
development and the Allegheny conference
on community development david
Ruppersberger is here he's the president
of the pittsburgh regional alliance an
affiliate of the Allegheny conference
for community development he's been
active in the Pittsburgh high-tech
community for over 30 years his
experience includes senior management
positions with Unisys Symbolics
and carnegie group inc CEO positions for
two high-tech startups in the pittsburgh
area and a partnership in a retail
business he served on many local boards
and is an executive fellow in the Center
for Economic Development at Carnegie
Mellon's Heinz College and he has a
degree in economics from the universe
University of Pittsburgh and with that
I'd like to welcome all of our esteemed
panelists for our session Gerry I'll
send it over to you thank you very much
Hannah and thank you all for being here
for this panel the Marcellus Shale
formation is the largest shale gas
formation in the country largest in the
sense of potential for producing actual
gas as you know well anybody from this
region
it's a formation that we've been
exploiting now for about 10 years I
guess in earnest and we will continue
for many decades to come one of the
questions is and the central question is
what are the benefits and what are the
costs in this region of the development
of that Marcellus shale resource are we
realizing the benefits and we maximizing
the benefits that we can get from that
resource
are we minimizing the cost or at least
containing the cost today we're going to
explore that with these outstanding
panels it's a really a wonderful group
that will complement each other very
well as you will hear as we proceed
let's start with you pat pat getty from
the bedding of
Foundation who thought a lot about this
question of getting the most out of the
Marcellus Shale resource how this region
can most benefit from it and I should
add and reinforce in cue that that he's
thought about this from a truly regional
perspective not just western
Pennsylvania not just Pennsylvania but
fact Pennsylvania Ohio West Virginia
yeah give us your thoughts about this
thank you I
the Benedum foundation has what for a
long time was just a curious geography
we serve all of West Virginia and
southwestern Pennsylvania but with the
advent of the shale opportunity that
that curious geography has become pretty
relevant we've been able to engage in in
regional efforts to try to truly in my
mind try to maximize the opportunity
which I think in front of my once
described by saying that prosperity
flows to where value is added to a raw
material and I can assure you every West
Virginian understands this essentially
for birth because they've seen that the
value the prosperity creation from coal
happen in places like Pittsburgh and
Cleveland in Detroit and what they're
left with is the the decline in jobs and
whatever the impacts in health and
environmental have been that's the way
West Virginia to see it so they really
understand that with this gas being
underfoot what is really important it's
not just a guerrilla shipment but to
actually add value to it in the region
and I'm convinced that the region has a
generational opportunity to develop
modern manufacturing around products
that are at least in part petrochemical
and origin things like carbon fibers all
kinds of endeavor it won't be
manufacturing like I knew 72 years ago
when I was born here but I think it's a
tremendous opportunity and I think we
tend to focus on Carnegie Mellon and
Pitt UPMC obviously if we're in
Pittsburgh but if you get outside of
Allegheny County the region is not
prospering this is really a chance to
change that and so that's that's on the
benefit side for sure as I would say
thanks been actually taking this sort of
a layer deeper Stacy Stacy
Elson the regional head of chevron you
joined forces with people's gas to do a
study but just this question of how to
maximize the benefits from shale gas
production forging the future you call
it could you tell us about that what
your findings were what your
recommendations were sure so let me just
say that it's not just large gas
resource for the u.s. it's one of the
largest scarce resources in the entire
world so it is truly truly significant
as you said last year Morgan and I
teamed up and we we work with a
consultant to really try and quantify
this question of what is the true
economic potential and that's important
now because only a fraction of the
resource has actually been produced so
if you're going to try and maximize the
economic benefit now is the time and
what we found was it quantified that
there was the potential for sixty
billion dollars of GDP growth 500,000
family-sustaining jobs and as much as
three billion dollars in tax revenue to
the state if the right strategies could
be put in place to maximize the
long-term economic value from the
resource I'm gonna move now to Dave
Ruppersberger so you heard Davis from
the Pittsburgh regional alliance and not
everybody knows what that is just to
help you understand suppose you're a
company in Seattle and you were thinking
about opening a second headquarters just
suppose you would go to the Pittsburgh
regional alliance deflect out whether
Pittsburgh was for you not to put you on
the spot Dave but you'll be happy to
know today's agenda is not about Amazon
but you're out there and you've got a
sense I think better than any of us this
kind of overall opportunities and
barriers to downstream development
through light at natural gas tell us
what you know so we've been focused
primarily on an
spec to the natural gas though not
everybody in other regions has the
advantage that we do our gas is wet gas
so from Marysville West about 25% of
what comes out of the grounds the
combination of ethane propane and butane
which surely can be used as fuel sources
just as the dry methane can but also
serves as a feedstock for chemicals so
the ethane gets turned to ethylene and
then polyethylene which is what shale is
going to be doing similar fashion you
could take propane in to propylene and
polypropylene and make plastics
materials with that those are markets
that are growing nationally and
internationally I tend to think that you
should look more regionally for those
markets because most of its transported
in pipelines so in North America for
instance we use about 3.4 million
barrels of natural gas liquids every day
and that's projected to double by 2026
so a lot of growth in that market in
particular we have some also some
advantages here I want to point out
about our ethane in particular we have a
lot of it right now we're exporting
almost all of it
in fact we are exporting all of it
except for what we're burning is fuel
but we have enough ethane here to supply
the shell cracker continue to export
exactly what we're exporting now and we
have enough left over for four or five
more crackers the scale of shell the
other thing is it's the cheapest ethane
in the world it's estimated we have
about a 30% cost advantage over any
other ethane world which means we can
take it and we can do things with it as
Pat was alluding to add value create
plastic pellets and ship them anywhere
in the world with the possible exception
of China more cheaply than anybody else
can but the other advantage we have is
we don't need to ship excuse me to
foreign markets because 700
within 700 miles of the shell cracker is
70 percent of the North American
marketplace the product that they're
going to produce so that's a huge
advantage as well
we go okay I want to make sure so what
are the things I know the Alliance is
part of the conference focuses on a lot
is the regional labor force in the kinds
of downstream job downstream development
your timeout requires a particular labor
force to support it what's the take on
that supply do we have the people we
need to support those jobs so there's
actually a part that comes before that
which is do we have enough labor to
build it and that was a real challenge
for us and as an economic developer we
don't often talk about a union labor
when we're trying to recruit people to
Pittsburgh but I can tell you without a
doubt that this project would not have
been completed without the full support
of 12 trade unions in Pittsburgh they
pulled together got the work force
together convinced shale that if they
didn't have enough people they could
train enough people to make this happen
once its operational there's another six
hundred people very highly technical
jobs they're gonna be required inside
defense to support this but probably two
or three times that many jobs outside
the fence
in other supply chain oriented companies
and we're working very hard with
partners like the Beaver County
Community College other partners in the
region to make sure that the workforce
is there and I'm sure Michael can help
on that as well be natural this segue to
Michael and shell but before we do I
want to sort of lay out the full extent
of the downstream opportunities and call
out Morgan Morgan O'Brien the president
CEO of people's gas to tell us a bit
about the retail side but also Morgan
this audience would not necessarily know
though a lot of car to keep people
hurting ability people would Morgan
Morgan's been a real visionary when it
comes to environmental side of the
retail distribution of natural gas and I
want to make sure you say something
about the partnership we've got what's
emu on methane weeks but so the retail
side in the
our mental leakage so yeah I think on
the retail side I mean I think Stacy
started with a you know the study that
we did in having a real analytics around
the potential and one of the areas that
we know is evident is that about more
than half of the people who live in the
state of Pennsylvania don't have access
to natural gas which in a state that's
housing the largest gas reserve in the
entire country and and one of the
largest in the world it feels like
that's clearly a huge opportunity both
for the market to develop here but also
to make sure that everybody in
Pennsylvania has access to it and has
the ability to enjoy the benefits and
and we literally two years ago started
going in it we're mostly talking rural
communities here I know it's close to
Pat's heart but these are communities
that are you know lower to middle class
and they can save on average between a
thousand of $1,500 a year in heaney
costs by converting to gas and so it's a
it's a huge economic opportunity for
I'll say the average person to have a
meaningful benefit coming from all this
incredible gas that we have but the
other side of it is as people start
thinking about and I was interested in
the the mayor of San Juan who was here
talking about the grid and the
reliability my background was 20 years
at Duquesne Light before I came to
people's and the idea of creating micro
grids and the ability to take this
natural gas because it's so plentiful so
reliable it's produced right here
and utilize that to convert it to gas
and we're starting to see more and more
of folks thinking about that aspect as
well as when we hear about nuclear and
coal and the challenges there the
opportunity to grow the grid with more
gas being generated here and being at
truly economic when I came over from
from Duquesne Light
I dared describe me as visionary I
actually would describe myself as being
scared I was so excited about the
economic opportunities for the region
and to be able to play a part in that as
a utility the biggest fear I had is that
I would screw it up and that my company
would screw it up under my leadership
and so one of the first things we did
was we reached out as I tell folks to
the smartest people I know which are the
folks here at Carnegie Mellon University
this is not a paid advertisement it's
literally the first folks we reach that
- and and what our our I'll say our
focus had never been and we knew it had
to be were on all the environmental
issues not with necessarily fracking and
the production of gas but literally
distributing it through the streets of
Pittsburgh and through all the
communities where everybody lives and we
knew I mean I knew the issues of having
old infrastructure having been at
Duquesne Light having lived in western
Pennsylvania seeing the bridges and the
roads and knowing all the infrastructure
issues that this part of the country has
we also have old water and gas lines
underground that we don't think about
and so for us we began immediately
accelerating the replacement of that old
pipe and X and replacing it as quickly
as we could as fast as we could manage
it but we really didn't have our hands
around what were those environmental
issues from having all this old pipe and
so through a partnership with Carnegie
Mellon University we've literally been
over the last couple years been going up
and down the streets of Pittsburgh
measuring the methane emissions coming
from our old pipes and that was really
important for us to understand one this
is a real issue it's an important issue
for people who live in this community
and if we didn't address it and take
ownership of it there's a strong
likelihood we're gonna screw this
opportunity up and so the folks at CMU
we've really integrated them into what
we call our risk management process
where we prioritize pipeline replacement
historically for a hundred years it's
based purely on reliability trying to
make sure we're reliable getting people
their gas we began anew prior
which overlaid that with the
environmental issues so where we had
significant environmental issues all of
a sudden a piece of pipe went high up on
the the pecking order for replacing that
pipe we also had the folks from CMU
measure the impacts on the on the air
that were breathing from the pipeline
replacement so it was really a before
and after and so we're at the point now
where we're going to begin literally
describing to the communities that we're
serving one the issues that were causing
by having these old pipes and then the
benefits of the pipe line replacement on
the air that we're breathing the the
next phase which the folks from seeing
you I think from the beginning were
anxious to do was not just to help us
prioritize the old pipe based on leakage
but actually be able to predict before
we had leakage the replacement of those
pipes and so that's really the next
phase of our partnership which is really
exciting so this is not fixing
environmental issues but avoiding those
environmental issues and so we're I
don't think it's visionary and I think
it's fear of screwing up everything
these folks are talking about but it's
been incredibly enlightening to people
in my industry and my the people that
are working for me to have some really
smart I'll call them kids because I'm an
old person coming into our offices
sitting down with our engineers and
educating them and and and our folks
embracing it which was obviously an
important part of this but we truly I
think are creating a different priority
system from a utility perspective then
I'd say most utilities have ever had and
I that's why I'm here today I can't say
enough about Carnegie Mellon and an
incredible asset that it is for this
region oh thanks for the promotion but
whether it was fear or vision the key
thing was you innovate and innovation
affects daily the production side but
also the environment
backside and you it's a great
demonstration it's a good segue to
Michael Mann from shale chemicals and as
you all know and as you've heard already
shale is building a very large cracker
facility up in in Beaver County and I
happen to know just from prior
interactions with Michael that shale
takes this idea of innovation in
Environmental Protection very seriously
I it's important to lay the groundwork
though first you can't do these things
about having some environmental impact
can't distribute guess you can't produce
gas and you can't use the gas downstream
in producing products when I have a
summon viral impact but what you can do
is to be innovative and do your best to
minimize those impacts so Michael tell
us what you're doing with your grab the
matically on what Morgan was speaking of
and and how companies are really
incentivized both for environmental and
then economic reasons to do a more
thorough and better job of keeping their
products in the pipe and and you know
preserving them so that they can be
produced into something as Pat said
that's value adding so I'll talk a
little bit about a typical manufacturing
facility could either be a refinery or a
chemical plant and then talk about how
we're doing things a little bit
differently where we're innovating to
offer an environmental benefit to the
region and ultimately we believe an
economic benefit to us as well so
typical manufacturing facility will have
a flare which is a safety and
environmental device where you have an
operational upset to relieve pressure
from that operational upset you send a
stream of gas or some mode of product up
the flare to relieve the pressure
situation it's occurring literally at
the ground level and most of the
emissions but not all most of the
emissions are burned off at the flare so
and and 98 99 % when I say most but
still when you have a foot a flaring
incident that particularly one that goes
for
a long time at a plan of a large scale
the emissions numbers that have to be
reported to the regulator
are typically pretty large so what we
did at this plant was we developed sort
of an internal pipeline network where we
will circulate the ethane if we have an
upset and and we'll be able to do this
for approximately 24 hours so if you
have a situation in a plant where in
within a shift or a shift or two they're
typically on 12-hour shifts you could
you could fix the whatever the issue was
that was causing the upset we will have
circulated the ethane not have all the
the emissions that would have been
reported and well there's an upfront
cost for us to build that on the backend
after years of operating there'll be a
benefit cuz we wouldn't have wasted all
the bad thing that we will have had to
send addition to the flare so that's not
something that you would typically see
down in the Gulf Coast or other parts of
the world it is I know it involves pipes
and an industry that people don't
normally think about innovative but it
is a way we've looked at things
differently and see how we can offer
both an environmental benefit to the
region immediately and ultimately an
economic benefit to us as well even
Michael I I want to come back to the
downstream development part of this I'm
sure the environmental side will come up
later as well and come back to you pad
and you Stacy get a little more specific
about the kinds of strategies or steps
we ought to be taking as a region to
maximize that benefit now Pat I know
you've worked to get the three states to
collaborate cooperate together you say
some more about that what kind of
cooperation there is going on within the
region yeah I'd be glad to actually the
the governor's at Pennsylvania West
Union Ohio signed an agreement in
October 2015 to collaborate around
downstream economic development and that
agreement was just free up for another
three years the week before last in
Houston and that's very unusual in
Mike's
and not all that many years ago the
Benedum foundation annual report was on
the issue can regionalism ever happen
and the conclusion of the experts we
interviewed was probably not and there's
something like an opportunity to turn
things around but one of the main
projects that's going to be critical the
development is creating storage
infrastructure and I have to call on
Brian Anderson who's the smartest guy I
know who's not on the faculty of
Carnegie Mellon who's a leader in
developing the assessment was done by
the Geological Survey offices of the
three states as to where storage could
happen and in the Gulf Coast storage is
there and easy for people to use and we
need something comparable of that to be
able to to store the NGLs in the region
that raw materials for downstream
manufacturing and it also permits the
opportunity for the price to be
stabilized and so forth so I can't speak
to it nearly as well as Brian could but
it is a an ongoing significant effort
and if that is accomplished I think that
that'll certainly be a turning of the
tide as far as the future of downstream
manufacturing in the region it's a
critically important piece of
infrastructure happily the Secretary of
Energy Rick Perry has been very
supportive I was in a meeting in
Morgantown when the secretary came to
Morgantown we were all holding our
breath and the first thing he said was
you folks need to be like people in
Texas you got to add value to your raw
material here in the region you know
what everybody kind of breathed a sigh
of relief it was afraid to say anything
because we got you know he opened a
meeting with where we were hoping it
would end but I I do think for now the
stars are aligned to try to pull this
together that's going to be important so
who's who's our lead in making this
storage happens this is a this is a role
for state government state governments
working together or is it industry
taking lead with the Commerce
Department's have been been very
collaborative I think that's been that's
been important I think
eventually this will have to be funded
through private equity it's not an
expensive development and where the
project is now is in the engineering
stage the geologic survey offices prove
that it can be done now the question is
you know where and and obviously this is
going to be a long and debatable process
to go through permitting on this but the
piping is underground the storage
facilities are also underground it's not
a it's not a noticeable piece of
infrastructure for the most part but it
is critical you've got to be able to
move the the NGOs around the region so
that manufacturing can take place in
different locations but I think the
there is interest in there is a storage
facility in Ohio that Goldman Sachs has
an interest in so I think that the
potential is there for the private
sector to get engaged at the right level
but at this point it's still an effort
to develop the engineering to show how
best to do stasi forging the future
report there were there specific
recommendations in terms of what
government or anybody else ought to be
doing to realize the benefits yes excuse
me there were specific recommendations
again you have this huge supply but the
regional demand is really really low and
so the key question was how can you
build regional demand more regional
demand so that the region really
benefits from the economic potential so
one of the strategies was what Morgan
said just getting more natural gas into
homes the second strategy was around how
to develop economic clusters that where
you can get let's say advanced
manufacturing data centers users of a
lot of natural gas that would want
low-cost natural gas to come and develop
these economic clusters and that plays
right into this region strength which is
robotics innovation manufacturing and so
that was this the second strategy was
around those clusters the third strategy
was actually around advancing the
infrastructure to export
some of the gas so there is so much gas
here that probably you could never use
it here even if you had a lot of data
centers and more crackers so getting
some of this gas to the Gulf Coast's
which can link it into global markets is
actually also important so Stacey oh I
don't mean to keep you on the spot here
but I'm gonna shift topics but keep you
talking Stacey and I are both
participants at something call the
center responsible shale development so
the premise for this for that Center
which is a collaboration between Chevron
shell eqt console now CNX EDF
Environmental Defense Fund the
Pennsylvania Environmental Council is
and if shale gas development is going to
occur then it ought to be done right
that is with minimal environmental
impact in the center through the
collaboration among these companies and
environmental groups created a set of
standards based on air and water impacts
so Stacey the question for you is so why
would Chevron participate in it it needs
to be said that there's standards
created by this Center or in every case
at least as stringent and in most cases
more stringent than the state standards
in any state in which Chevron was
working and true for the other companies
also so why why would you do that well
first I want to thank you
Jerry actually has served for five years
as the the board chair for this really
important organization and it's not
always been an easy job so it's been
nice to work with you since I got here
on that and we can declare a success I
think Jerry in that like you said that
we have raised the standard actually the
regulatory standard because it makes
sense for all of us to operate to the
highest economic
standard environmental standard it and
y'all touched on this as well right
I mean emissions accidents pollution is
not good for any of us and it's not good
for our industry and so I think you'll
find globally anywhere that Chevron
operates we're operating to the highest
standard that we can I I would just add
that the premise for the center is
belief that companies need a quote
social license to Hungary that is they
have to operate in a way so that the
society in which they are operating
believes that they are doing the best
they can can in their in their
production so Ana we're at that point
where we could allow for some questions
if maybe we have a little time for that
we have a couple of questions so one of
the questions that's come is is what do
you see as the R&D and innovation needs
for downstream natural gas use R&D needs
downstream everybody wants you to answer
that Dave sure I have a good answer for
it off the cuff this is a very
traditional industry in general what
word we're still three to four years
away from product for Michele cracker
and once we get that and there's an
abundance of residents plastic residents
we do expect to see a lot more Rd in
terms of product development customer
engagement but it's I'm not in a
position to kind of predict which
direction that's gonna go maybe Michael
could find a little more I can add a
little something here um so that talked
about the tri-state coalition and a
study they recently put out they also
put one out last year at the same
conference and that one highlighted how
Pennsylvania is is really kind of
well-positioned to take the next step
here because there's a college and
university a Penn State Erie has the the
Barron
last of school and Penn College has a
school that also focuses specifically on
plastics engineering and frankly that
was a kind of a surprise good surprise
learning for shell and we'll definitely
see some opportunities to partner there
with those two institutions and what
they're they're faculty and students and
and draw up on their talents to look at
future R&D happenings at our facility
Morgan's here I'm just gonna add the and
again I don't understand the subject
matter but the the McKenzie studies have
recommended that carbon fibers in future
but for chemical feedstocks would be
important for the manufacturing future
for the downstream because among other
things they can be made recyclable and
that drives the price down to make it
competitive carbon fibers are stronger
and lighter than other materials and
Mackenzie's report at least to Ohio and
West Virginia to that they've done I
think this might be referred to in the
Pennsylvania report also is that this is
a clear opportunity for the region as to
the Rd part I think clearly this region
has strengths in in what Carnegie Mellon
is strong and the one doubts the world
leadership on that score who is really
good in the in the downstream
development of future products is a
little bit more spread out I know that
there's a German company that's looking
at it as a recycling facility for carbon
fibers in the UK that's looking to
create one here and they get their work
done and an oak ridge so I think maybe
that's something we need to actually put
some thought into that very issue who is
who are the sources for the Rd for the
the future product development yeah you
know and I think the attitude that we
took with Creneti Mellon was to
basically have an open mind and listen
and as we began that dialogue we were
introduced you know I we basically said
you know any ideas and things that
people are working on that you think
would apply and make us better at what
we're doing knowing what our mission is
we'd love to be the sandbox that people
played in and and since that time you
know we now have
I call them drones but I the autonomous
flying devices that actually are
basically flying along the bridges in
western Pennsylvania that we have quite
a few of and a lot of them have gas
lines underneath and typically
historically we would have folks
underneath those bridges checking those
pipes these drones now go flying through
the air and give us better better data
and it's obviously much safer we've also
been introduced to a robotics strategy
that literally threw gas lines as small
as four inches a robot can go through
and literally take photos of the inside
of the pipe to give us a real real-time
depiction of of what that looks like and
they also have the ability to seal
joints particularly in some of the older
bigger pipes and so and then the last
innovation that we've we sort of been
introduced with our relationship here is
the idea of putting a fuel cell in
somebody's home combined with a battery
I know there's a lot of discussions
around battery where you basically take
the natural gas that you know we have
the capacity to deliver to your home and
literally convert it to electricity in
your house without any combustion and
then that that fuel cell which is a very
proven technology in big data centers
and other technology it's actually
making it economic on a smaller scale
that's been the challenge in that
industry we're through the partnership
that we have we're gonna be introducing
a hundred fuel cells over the next 12
months into people's homes who would be
willing to see how this works but so I
think you know I think from on our end
of it we we've tried to be you know an
open door to let others come and help us
think this troops I think that how we
how we done things in the past is
changing so quickly that nearly
everything that you know people talk
about in this region that Amazon is
excited about all these other things
traditional industries like mine can can
embrace and really partner with some of
these really smart young people
and I so I think it's we're just at the
beginning of it and I think it's gonna
be dramatically probably more quickly
than anything make us so much more
responsible and that fear that I started
with not only put that to ease but also
help you and people that we serve come
up with environmental answers that make
economic sense that take advantage of
this and as you say that those always
some environmental impacts but taking
those next steps I think there's a lot
of opportunities for traditional ways
changing and making it a much much
better path forward thank you Anna
time for one more we have a question is
the increasing share of natural gas for
power generation causing any shifts in
your priority for replacement and
upgrade of old infrastructure I think
that's for uh no it's I guess it's for
me I would say what's really you know we
have changed our infrastructure strategy
almost completely around the
environmental impacts I would say that
nothing more has more impact on how we
were and how we would have done it
versus how we're doing it
what pipes were replacing those old
pipes with and the ability to
potentially serve more gas to our
customers and bring more gas in I think
is is probably an answer to that
question we are thinking of the future
of this region not the past how we used
it so we've got building capacity to
serve rural communities building
capacity to bring more generation online
that historically have been using coal
and nuclear but then also looking at all
the downstream opportunities to say
we're not replacing pipe for pipe we're
actually looking at what the future of
this region looks like and we want
infrastructure to be in place so that as
these opportunities come about we can
serve them
else what up whirring on that one well
Anna noting that the last panel ran over
a little bit in bid into heart time how
about one more question you've caught me
off guard here well let me let me
acknowledge that the moderator of the
last session was also your boss so I
guess that explains some of it but what
at mine that's right so there's a couple
of questions related to pipelines okay
and the export of this fuel resource so
are there any plans on thinking about
keeping that resource here for both
people and workforce and productivity
good stays to restate my earlier comment
around how large the resource is the
McKinsey study that we worked on did not
model that it was possible to use all
that gas here and so it makes economic
sense to export it out of the region and
if you can get it to the Gulf Coast
the gas can be liquefied it can go on a
barge and it can go to any demand center
anywhere in the world and so you know I
think it's better to capture as most
economic value as you can in this region
and that's what if these strategies are
successful but it's actually you can't
use all the gas here it's so big is what
the study found yeah I think one of the
statistics that we saw and I use this if
I'm talking to Governor wolf or anybody
and this is the fence of the
regionalization that you've created but
if you just look at what's in
Pennsylvania of the Marcellus and Utica
in just in Pennsylvania it's enough to
power to provide the United States its
entire energy needs so if there were no
other energy source
other than this like the next 15 years
and so there's a lot of gas here and
we're never gonna be able to utilize all
of it here and I think that's the
obvious and I would just add from an
economic development standpoint I said
we're particularly interested in natural
gas liquids our job is to bring more
crackers and more propane facilities to
the region to use this NGLs the problem
is it all comes out of the ground
together so if we want the natural gas
liquids to turn into plastics to build
manufacturing facilities we need to
bring the methane out with it and we
can't use it all here so we're going to
have to export at least some of it so
let me just close this by saying
reminding you where we started we're
sitting on top of the largest shale gas
reserve in the country or one of the
largest in the world if we're going to
use fossil fuels in many people at this
university here committed to finding a
way to reduce our dependence on fossil
fuels but if you're gonna use them and
you want to use them wisely and do in a
way that produces
maximum benefit I will tell you from my
perspective having interacted with all
the people on this panel and their
colleagues in in this industry and
environmental groups we're fortunate to
have the particular companies that we do
have exploiting this resource yes there
are viral impacts and they're creating
our admissions or discharges but as you
heard and I saw I've seen sort of behind
the scenes they were genuinely committed
to doing it with the smallest impact
that you know please join me in thanking
this panel
[Applause]